la gnôle déjà ou été jeté par texto on a
jeté par texto vous êtes vous avez été
jetée où vous avez jeté
j'ai jeté à mons et je suis désolé ça ne
risque pas de changer ce que la mauvaise
après-midi elle emilie j'ai ma non mais
c'est bizarre vous imaginez au lit ce
n'est pas possible elle avait le même
prénom que moi un cd c'est gary sofres à
ces sites juste ça g et voilà donc c'est
un peu compliqué et en fait l'autre
souci qui avait c'est que quand elle
écrivait ses textos elle écrivait en
majuscules déjà l'impression qu'elle
m'engueuler achats et en plus elle
faisait plein de fautes d'orthographe
donc ça me rend dingue doivent trouver
ça c'est une raison pour l'ajouter par
texto ben j'ai pas eu le courage de le
faire en bref je suis allé m'excuser
on est là le sens de près de 7 personnes
d'après sa dette bien longtemps je
rappelle que ça fait neuf ans que j en
coupe donc l'exception vous l'avez dit
quoi je sais plus christopher il
m'arrivait quelque chose d'horrible
moi qui suis souvent sur les
applications de rencontre parce que je
cherche l'amour je suis à la rencontre
la recherche adacore rien une fois
j'avais un rencard avec une fille du
coup dans un bar et on devait se
retrouver devant et en fait elle a dû
observer de loin elle m'a envoyé un
texto elle m'a dit en fait ça va pas le
faire ces origines kyrielle a au fond la
barre alors moi j'ai jamais fait ça à
bravo matin et en bulles de la rupture
peut-être art mode s'embrouille en mode
à la rouille d'abord dwalin faut
vraiment qu'on parle en revanche ça
arrive avec une amie à moi s'il te plaît
avec le père de ses enfants donc c'est
vraiment énorme allons donc on est passé
en fait on n'est pas dans des échanges
en mode en partant du flirt
on vit ensemble on a des enfants
ensemble et le mec avait pas les cojones
de lui dire en face
il a attendu lentement de vacances et
lui envoyer le message pour le dépressif
sur lightroom et je vous jure c'est vrai
incroyable à cannes je suis j'étais tout
seul
si j'étais maire
alors comme d'habitude et à la bible
alors j'avais de quoi pas en même temps
me choque un peu plus jeune amaury alors
mais je me suis trompé dans de très
nombreux et bien voici message et il m'a
répondu dégage voilà j'ai dit bon bah
voilà je me suis fait jeter wayne se
guérit c'était un problème du bebop à
l'époque hein c'est pas trop à qui on
dit qu'il est allé me chercher
on a en a cherché les messages qui ont
été envoyés de rupture soit des gros
gros vent on les a catégorisé on va
démarrer par par les plus drôles
il ya celui ci d'abord quoi de neuf
please chute due au redoux
mais quand c'est toi qui rend ses moyens
on en a un autre sur une échelle de 1 à
10 à combien suis-je plus importante
qu'à clasico je te conseille de te
propose elle a posé la question et un
dernier
je me fais chier bafin où nous je suis
pas ta nou nou encore ça va ça va aller
là là c'était plutôt gentil drôle va
c'était plutôt aux antilles c'est plutôt
drôle
on a monté d'un cran regardez est ce
qu'on les a qu'attends tu de moi ou
juste tout tu fermes super bien allez
encore un autre en tout cas ma
proposition est alléchante tu dois bien
l'avouer
mort de rire celle qui propose les
beaucoup moins non non c'est franchement
superbe aloqa et c'est des vrais texto
bien sûr 1